Like a lot of high schools, it had a social structure like the Balkans during the Yugoslav civil war, totally divided. It was jocks, stoners, and farmers, each with their own native dress, each with their own customs and traditions, each with their own music. The jocks listened to classic rock, the farmers to country music, the stoner kids to hard core. The only band they all agreed on? Metallica.
和许多高中一样，这里有着像南斯拉夫内战期间巴尔干半岛那样的社会结构，完全分裂。有运动员、瘾君子和农场小子，每个人都有自己的着装风格、习俗传统和音乐偏好。运动员听经典摇滚，农场小子听乡村音乐，瘾君子听硬核摇滚。他们唯一都认可的乐队？Metallica。
Metallica was kind of big.
Metallica当时相当火。
Metallica is one of the few groups that can bring people together.
Metallica是少数能把不同人群凝聚在一起的乐队之一。
That's right. That's right. It knows no boundaries.
没错。没错。它不受任何界限的阻隔。
It knows no boundaries.
它不受任何界限的阻隔。
The place, Menomonie, Wisconsin, a small town an hour east of St. Paul. Our guide, a resident who has chosen to appear here under the name Jim Steel. The situation, a night toward the end of the school year when jocks, stoners, and farmers are together, getting along, no conflicts. Jim and some stoners even convince a farmer kid named Chad Richter to smoke pot for the first time.
地点是威斯康星州的梅诺莫尼，圣保罗以东一小时车程的小镇。我们的向导是一位自称吉姆·斯蒂尔的当地居民。故事发生在学年末的一个晚上，运动员、瘾君子和农场小子聚在一起，相处融洽，没有冲突。吉姆甚至和几个瘾君子一起说服了一个叫查德·里希特的农场小子，让他第一次尝试了大麻。
We're hanging out. And then we decide to go to this party. It's at a place called The Pole Shed. It's about 10 miles out of town, way out in the country. And really, it's just a machine shed for storing farm equipment. I'm not even sure who owned the property.
我们聚在一起。然后我们决定去参加一个派对。地点在一个叫“电线杆棚屋”的地方。离镇上大约10英里，在很远的乡下。说实话，那只是个存放农具的机器棚。我甚至不知道是谁拥有的这块地。
So we pull in. There's about five of us in the car. And we're feeling pretty good, looking forward to more beer and hanging out on a slow Friday in Menomonie. And Chad Richter, the guy that had smoked dope for the first time that night, gets out there. A few minutes pass, and we're just hanging out, milling around, talking. I don't think there's even music out in the middle of the country, just hanging out by the shed.
我们把车开了进去。车里大概有五个人。我们感觉很不错，期待着在这个梅诺莫尼平淡的周五晚上能喝更多的啤酒，聚在一起消遣。查德·里希特，那个当晚第一次抽大麻的家伙，下了车。几分钟过去了，我们只是聚在一起，四处走动、聊天。我想在那种乡下地方甚至都没有音乐，大家只是聚在棚屋边。
And all of a sudden, we start to notice there's something going on back in the gravel driveway. It's this guy, Brady Henderson, who's Chad Richter's best friend. And Brady, he was an all-state wrestler, a really, really small kid, but wiry, and tough, and pretty mean. And he's in Chad's face, just shoving him and getting angry with him. And so people start congregating, like it always happens.
突然，我们注意到碎石车道那边出了点状况。那是布雷迪·亨德森，查德·里希特的死党。布雷迪是个州立摔跤手，个子非常非常小，但筋骨结实、强悍，而且挺刻薄的。他正凑在查德面前，推搡着他，对他发火。于是人群开始聚集，就像往常发生的那样。
And the next thing I see is Brady Hanson does some crazy move, just tackles Chad, brings him right down to the gravel and punches him right in the face, twice, hard, right to the face. And he grabs him by the shirt. He's shaking him. I'm still like, what is going on? These guys are best friends. And Brady screams at Chad. He says, "Chad, you're a farmer. Farmers don't smoke pot. We drink beer."
接下来我看到布雷迪·汉森做了一个疯狂的动作，他直接把查德扑倒在碎石地上，对着他的脸狠狠地打了两拳，非常用力。他抓住他的衬衫摇晃着。我还是觉得很纳闷，到底发生了什么？这俩人不是死党吗？布雷迪冲查德尖叫道：“查德，你是个农场小子。农场小子不抽大麻。我们喝啤酒。”
This is what happens if you violate the rules of your own social group. This is what happens if insiders suddenly see you as an outsider.
这就是违反自己社交圈规则的下场。这就是当圈内人突然把你视为圈外人时会发生的事。
And I don't think Chad ever smoked marijuana again after that.
我想查德在那之后再也没碰过大麻。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of different kinds of writers and reporters and performers to bring you stories on that theme. Today's program, One Of Us. How you get included, how you get kicked out of any group you can name.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选定一个主题，邀请各类作家、记者和表演者为大家讲述关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“我们中的一员”。关于如何被接纳，以及如何被任何你所能说出的团体踢出门外。
Act One today, My Crap Life. We're going to start at the moment in American life when the division between outsiders and insiders is usually the most intense, high school. When the wrong haircut can change everything.
今天的第一幕，“我那糟糕的生活”。我们将从美国生活中最强烈的圈内与圈外对立时刻开始：高中。在那里，不合适的发型就能改变一切。
Act Two, My Work Life. The story of one public radio reporter who goes down to tell a very public-radio-style story about regular working Joes down Louisiana way. And what happens when the working Joes decide that he is not just an outsider, but, in fact, is out to destroy them. And how he ends up hanging off the side of a freighter in the middle of the night, worried for his life.
第二幕，“我的工作生活”。这是一个公共广播记者的故事，他深入路易斯安那州，打算去讲一个典型的公共广播风格的故事，讲述普通蓝领工人的生活。然而，当这些工人认定他不仅是个外来者，甚至还是想毁掉他们的人时，事情发生了转折。他最终被困在半夜的货轮侧面，为自己的性命担忧。
Act Three, My Church Life. Writer Susan Bergman finds herself, somehow, named one of the top young Christians in America and wonders if she wants to be part of the group. And what happens when she visits with the other top young Christians. Stay with us.
第三幕，“我的教会生活”。作家苏珊·伯格曼发现自己竟被提名为美国顶级青年基督徒之一，并开始怀疑自己是否想成为这个群体的一员。当她去拜访其他顶级青年基督徒时，事情又会如何发展？请继续收听。
Act One, My Crap Life. There's this beautiful old cemetery near my home here in Chicago called Graceland Cemetery. And not long ago, when the weather was still nice, I was wandering around there with a friend. It was a pretty day. And we were talking about this and that. And got to talk about the cemetery, and death, and where our bodies would end up, a very cheerful fall conversation.
第一幕，我那糟糕的生活。在我家附近的芝加哥有一座美丽的古老墓地，叫格雷斯兰公墓。不久前，天气还不错的时候，我和朋友在那里闲逛。那是美好的一天。我们聊着各种琐事，话题转到了墓地、死亡以及我们死后的归宿，这真是个令人愉快的秋日对话。
And somehow, in this conversation, I realized suddenly, if I should die, if I die suddenly, my parents would collect my body and take it back to Baltimore, a place that I have spent-- no offense-- a place that I have spent my entire life trying to run from. And that is where I would spend eternity.
不知怎么的，在谈话中我突然意识到，如果我死了，如果我突然去世，我的父母会把我的遗体带回巴尔的摩，那个我花了——没有冒犯的意思——那个我穷极一生试图逃离的地方。那将是我永恒的安息之地。
But anyway, your family makes claims on you. And for many people, for most people, I think, the time of life when the claim is the greatest, other than when you try to throw a wedding, is adolescence. They want you to act like them. And you want to act like some other group, a group that may not even accept you as one of their own. We have this story from Tim Melley.
总之，你的家庭会对你提出要求。对于许多人，我想对于大多数人来说，除了筹备婚礼之外，人生中这种要求最强烈的时期就是青春期。他们希望你变得像他们一样。而你却想成为另一个群体的一员，一个甚至可能根本不接纳你的群体。我们有来自蒂姆·梅利的这个故事。
He looks up and says, me and my brother are getting a haircut on the front porch after dessert. Three days before summer and he's going to cut our hair. I ask him, "Can't we wait until school's over?" "No," he says, "we can't." I say, "Please." And he says, "No, tonight's the night."
他抬头说，我和我弟弟吃完甜点后要在前门廊理发。夏天还有三天就要结束了，他要在那时给我们剪头发。我问他：“不能等学校放假了吗？”“不行，”他说，“我们不能。”我说：“求你了。”他说：“不行，就是今晚。”
I say, "Dad, can't we just wait three days?" And he says, "What difference does it make?" I say, "It makes a big difference." He says, "Why?" "Because." "Because why?" "Because it does."
我说：“爸，就不能等三天吗？”他说：“这有什么区别吗？”我说：“区别可大了。”他说：“为什么？”“因为。”“因为什么？”“因为它就是有区别。”
My little crap brother says, "Oooh, you got a girlfriend. You got a girlfriend." I say, "No, I don't." "Oooh," he says, "you got a girlfriend. You got a girlfriend. He's got a girlfriend. He's got a girlfriend." "Shut up, butt hole," I say.
我那该死的弟弟说：“噢，你有女朋友了。你有女朋友了。”我说：“我没有。”“噢，”他说，“你有女朋友了。你有女朋友了。他有女朋友了。他有女朋友了。”“闭嘴，混蛋，”我说。
They're laughing now, even my sister, who's too small to get it. "Oh ho," says my father, "so that's it. Well." "It is not," I say. "I just don't want to look like a loser with one of your army cuts." "Well," he says, and he's smiling, "if you've got a girlfriend, why don't you tell us who she is?" "I don't," I say, "I don't."
他们现在笑作一团，连我那还太小听不懂的妹妹也在笑。“噢哈，”我父亲说，“原来是这样。好吧。”“才不是，”我说。“我只是不想留着你那军人发型，看起来像个失败者。”“嗯，”他说，微笑着，“如果你有女朋友，为什么不告诉我们她是谁？”“我没有，”我说，“我没有。”
But my throat's lumping up. I never had a girlfriend. My mother says, "Don't let them get to you. Just laugh it off." But my father says, "You better not start your goddamn crying, for Christ's sake." My eyes fill. My brother is laughing and whooping.
但我的喉咙哽咽了。我从来没有过女朋友。我母亲说：“别让他们影响你。笑笑就过去了。”但父亲说：“看在上帝的份上，你最好别开始你那该死的哭泣。”我的眼眶湿润了。我弟弟在旁边又叫又笑。
"God almighty," my father says, "I have never seen such a goddamn sissy in my life." I say, "Oh, yeah? Well, Charlie D'Amato said it was OK to cry." And my father says, "Who's he?" And I say, "My French teacher." And he says, "He lets you call him Charlie? What is he, new?" And I say, "Yes, he is. And he's excellent."
“天哪，”我父亲说，“我这辈子没见过这么该死的软蛋。”我说：“哦，是吗？查理·达马托老师说哭没关系。”我父亲说：“他是谁？”我说：“我的法语老师。”他说：“他让你叫他查理？他是新来的吗？”我说：“是的，他是。而且他非常棒。”
And my father says, "Yeah, well, he sounds like a classic fruit to me." And I say, "You don't even know him. You don't even know anything about me. You don't even care."
我父亲说：“是吗，嗯，听起来他就是个典型的娘娘腔。”我说：“你根本不认识他。你对我一无所知。你根本不在乎。”
I could hear my loser voice lumping up on me, and my eyes filling again. So I got up and went to my room. I could hear them laughing behind my back. I slammed my door. I lay on the bed and plugged my ears and listened to my heart beating. I could still feel them pressing down on me like deep water, trying to make me nothing.
我能听见自己那失败者的声音哽咽了，眼里又充满了泪水。所以我站起身回了房间。我能听见他们在背后嘲笑我。我重重地关上了门。我躺在床上，堵住耳朵，听着自己的心跳。我依然能感觉到他们像深水一样压着我，试图让我变得一无是处。
I got my black comb out of my back pocket, which was not my comb, but Chris Sanford's, who gave it to me because I lost mine. I combed my hair right down over my eyes, where my dad hated it. I got to thinking about his gun. I knew where it was. I had held it, black and heavy in my hand before.
我从后口袋里拿出我的黑色梳子，那其实不是我的，是克里斯·桑福德的，因为我弄丢了自己的，他才给了我。我把头发梳得盖住眼睛，这正是父亲最讨厌的样子。我开始想到他的枪。我知道它在哪。我以前曾把它握在手里，黑沉沉的。
I could go right back down there and get them all on their knees, crying and bawling themselves, begging me not to do something stupid. I had worked it all out plenty of times. My dad would have to say, "We are sorry, son. It's our fault." I'd make him say it again, twice. But still, I'd wave the gun all around at them like a lunatic.
我可以立刻下去让他们全都跪下，让他们哭得稀里哗啦，求我别做傻事。我已经在脑海里演练过很多次了。我爸得说：“对不起，儿子。都是我们的错。”我会让他再说一遍，说两遍。但我还是会像个疯子一样挥舞着枪对着他们。
I'd say, "I don't think you're sorry enough for what you did." Then I'd go in the living room and pretend to blow my head off, put a slug right through the floor. That would be pretty sweet, watching them run in, wide-eyed and wailing. I saw myself in the mirror, smiling about it. Then I remembered the haircut and got to thinking again.
我会说：“我觉得你们对自己的所作所为道歉得还不够真诚。”然后我会走进客厅，假装朝自己的脑袋开枪，把子弹直接打穿地板。那一定很美妙，看着他们眼珠子瞪得大大的，哀嚎着跑进来。我在镜子里看到了自己，露出了微笑。然后我记起了理发的事，又开始思考起来。
What if Holly Heyward invited me to her end-of-the-year party? What if I get a note in my locker with hearts from Holly Heyward, and it says, come to her party? What if one of her friends at lunch says, "Holly likes you. She wants you to come to her party." I couldn't go to a party like that with one of my dad's haircuts, no way, no how.
如果霍莉·海沃德邀请我去参加她的学年末派对呢？如果我在储物柜里收到一张带有爱心的、来自霍莉·海沃德的纸条，说让我去参加派对呢？如果午餐时她的朋友对我说：“霍莉喜欢你。她想让你去参加派对。”我绝不可能留着我爸给的那种发型去参加那样的派对，绝不可能。
Plus, I couldn't smoke for squat yet. I had taken four puffs of Mrs. Beech's ragged, lipstick-covered cigarette butt in her kitchen, where I fed her dog. I was coughing like a pussy. "You can't go to a party if you can't take a good hit," says Chris Sanford.
另外，我还不怎么会抽烟。我在喂狗的厨房里，抽了四口比奇夫人丢下的、沾着口红的烟蒂。我咳嗽得像个懦夫。“如果你连烟都抽不好，你就去不了派对，”克里斯·桑福德说。
Then I get to thinking about it again, lying there. I was sitting next to Chris when it happened, The Holly Incident. Sanford and I are in every class together. He has long hair and silky-like shirts with very intense patterns that my mother will never get me because they give you bad B.O., according to her. Chris Sanford's name is written on desks with heart-shaped vowels. Girls gives me notes for him.
躺在那里，我又开始思考。发生“霍莉事件”时我就坐在克里斯旁边。桑福德和我每节课都在一起。他留着长发，穿着那种图案非常夸张的丝质衬衫，我妈绝不会给我买这种衣服，因为她说那样会有体臭。克里斯·桑福德的名字被写在课桌上，元音字母变成了心形。女生们总是把给他的纸条交给我。
The Holly Incident happened in English. Miss Rothstein was talking like a robot. She was saying, "As flies to the wanton gods," saying, "Two roads diverged on a darkling plain," blah, blah. "The wine-dark sea was going over some crazy cliff," blah, blah, blah. Sanford and I were in the back row because in our English class, there are no major back-rowers of the type who will hang in the bathrooms and stick your head down the toilet or set fire to your hair if you look at them.
“霍莉事件”发生在英语课上。罗斯坦小姐讲课像个机器人。她说：“如飞虫之于残暴的神明，”说着，“两条路在昏暗的平原上分叉，”巴拉巴拉。“酒红色的海洋翻过了一座疯狂的悬崖，”等等。桑福德和我坐在后排，因为在我们的英语课上，没有那种会躲在厕所里、如果你敢看他们就敢把你的头按进马桶或点燃你头发的“后排流氓”。
Miss Rothstein was talking. But we were looking out the window to the hill, where kids go to smoke drugs because Fleagle, the big-butt principal, can't get up the hill fast enough. And Holly Heyward was coming down the hill with Ingrid Bentley, the two of them laughing, faded T-shirts and tight blue jeans, flicking their blond hair back until they went out of sight below. My brain was veering off course.
罗斯坦小姐在讲课。但我们望着窗外的小山坡，那是孩子们去偷偷吸大麻的地方，因为弗利格，那个大屁股校长，根本没法那么快爬上山。霍莉·海沃德和英格丽德·本特利正从山坡上走下来，两人笑着，穿着褪色的T恤和紧身牛仔裤，不停地撩着金色的头发，直到消失在视线之外。我的大脑彻底乱了。
Miss Rothstein said, "Chris, would you like to tell us what Bartleby likes to say?" And Chris said, "I'd prefer not to." And Miss Rothstein beamed at him like Mrs. Cleaver. The dude was so smart.
罗斯坦小姐说：“克里斯，你想告诉我们巴特比喜欢说什么吗？”克里斯说：“我宁愿不。”罗斯坦小姐像比弗夫人一样对他灿烂一笑。这家伙太聪明了。
A minute later, Holly and Ingrid walked past our classroom windows and waved at Chris. I was between Chris and the window, so they could have been waving at me. But I only smiled back, since the dumbest thing you can do, besides having to go to the blackboard with a boner, is wave back at someone who is waving at the person behind you.
一分钟后，霍莉和英格丽德经过我们的教室窗户，冲克里斯招手。我就在克里斯和窗户之间，所以她们也可能是在冲我招手。但我只是回以微笑，因为除了不得不因为起了生理反应而走上黑板前之外，最蠢的事莫过于冲着在你背后的人招手的人回礼。
Holly's cheeks were bright red with something. Miss Rothstein was talking blah, blah about the meaning of silence and didn't see Holly and Ingrid laughing and making hand signs at Chris, didn't see me in the middle, tipping back against the wall in my chair, trying not to let the legs slip out from under since that is also bone-headed in the extreme. Holly stuck her laughing head in the back window and said, in her throaty voice, "Hey." She looked over toward Miss Rothstein, who was still blah, blah, blahing, and said, "Hey, Chris, who's your friend? He's cute."
霍莉的脸颊因某种原因变得通红。罗斯坦小姐还在巴拉巴拉讲着沉默的意义，没看到霍莉和英格丽德在笑，也没看到她们冲克里斯做手势，也没看到我夹在中间，椅子后倾倚在墙上，极力保持平衡不让椅子腿滑出去，因为那样也显得极端笨拙。霍莉把她那张带着笑意的脸探进后窗，用她那沙哑的声音说：“嘿。”她看向罗斯坦小姐，后者还在巴拉巴拉地讲着，说道：“嘿，克里斯，你朋友是谁？他很可爱。”
The sky was pale blue, and her cheeks red, and her hair wispy blond, and she said, "Hey, Chris, who's your friend? He's cute." Tall Holly, swaying, smiling, playing hooky, and probably stoned. I was looking at my desk, thinking, "Do something. Do something. Do something." Then Sanford held up his notebook with my name in big letters. And I turned back to see them gone.
天空呈浅蓝色，她的脸颊绯红，金发轻柔飘逸，她说了：“嘿，克里斯，你朋友是谁？他很可爱。”高挑的霍莉，摇曳着，微笑着，逃着课，可能还吸了毒。我盯着课桌，心里想着：“做点什么。做点什么。做点什么。”然后桑福德举起笔记本，上面写着我的大名。我转过头，她们已经不见了。
Leaving class, Miss Rothstein gave Chris her toothpaste smile. And we floated into the corridor swarm, everything moving away slow like we were on a new planet. The floors were all tilted, and I had to lean with the slope a bit just to walk upright.
下课时，罗斯坦小姐给了克里斯一个像牙膏广告般灿烂的笑容。我们飘进了走廊的人群中，一切移动得如此缓慢，仿佛我们在一个新星球。地板全是倾斜的，我不得不顺着坡度侧身才走得直。
He was coming to get me. I could hear him thumping up the stairs to my room. The door opened. He said, "Get downstairs and eat your dinner." I didn't get up. I was starving.
他来抓我了。我能听见他咚咚地走上楼梯来到我房间。门开了。他说：“下去把饭吃了。”我没动。我饿坏了。
He stared at me like to say he was going to put me through the wall again, so I sat up. I swung my feet to the floor and sat on the edge of the bed. I looked right at him, thinking, "I am so sick of his crap every day." He said, "What the hell's the matter with you, anyway?" I said, "Nothing. What's the matter with you?" But I said the second part real quiet.
他盯着我，那眼神仿佛要再次把我推向墙壁，所以我坐了起来。我把脚垂到地板上，坐在床边。我直视着他，心想：“我真是厌透了他每天的那副破样子。”他说：“你到底怎么回事？”我说：“没什么。你呢？”但我后半句说得很轻。
"What's that, smart guy?" He said, his lip coming up in the corner. He looked at me some more that way, but I wouldn't say. He said, "I'm going to cut your brother's hair first. I better not have to come back up here and get you." He left, and I lay back down on the bed. I heard the porch door open and shut, open and shut, open and shut. And then I could hear the whine of the clippers.
“你说什么，聪明人？”他说，嘴角上扬。他又用那种眼神盯着我，但我不再吭声。他说：“我先去给你弟剪头发。最好别让我再上来找你。”他离开了，我躺回床上。我听见门廊的门开了又关，开了又关，开了又关。然后我听到了理发器嗡嗡的声音。
I thought, "I'll jerk my head and make him cut my ear off like Picasso. That would be sweet, him dropping to his knees, blubbering how he never meant to hurt me so bad." I could already see it. I'd have a pale white skull, my hair sticking up so short. I was thinking the places I could go free period to avoid haircut jokes and Holly.
我想：“我要猛地一扭头，让他像毕加索那样把我的耳朵剪掉。那肯定很美妙，看着他跪下来，泪流满面地说他从没想过要伤害我这么深。”我已经能预见那个场景了。我会有一个苍白的骷髅头，头发剪得极短。我在想空余时间能去哪里躲避关于发型的笑话和霍莉。
All I wanted was one of those laughs when I said something to her, slow motion, head back, hair floating through space, everything layered under it, the other guys looking at me, everything rolling under me like the sea. I couldn't go to Holly's party now. But at least The Ricky Kenickie Problem was solved.
我想要的只是当我跟她说话时能有的那种笑声，慢动作，头后仰，头发在空间中飘浮，每一层都随之摆动，其他男生看着我，一切像海洋一样在我身下翻滚。现在我没法去参加霍莉的派对了。但至少“瑞奇·肯尼基问题”解决了。
At least I wouldn't get killed at the party in a repeat of The Bathroom Incident, me standing there, saying nothing, fumbling with my zipper, and having trouble whizzing all because we were in there alone mid-period. And Kenickie said, "What are you doing, faggot? Beating off in there? Hey, fatso? You beating it?"
至少我不会在派对上重演“厕所事件”，当时我站在那，一言不发，摆弄着拉链，因为中间休息时厕所里只有我们俩，却尿不出来。肯尼基说：“你在干嘛，娘娘腔？在里面打飞机吗？嘿，肥猪？你在打飞机吗？”
His gang had cut a kid up in the locker room. And he beat a kid half to death in the crappers one day. And he was looking at me twisted. I had never seen his bad skin up so close before.
他的团伙在更衣室里划伤了一个孩子。有一天，他在厕所里把一个孩子打得半死。他斜着眼睛看着我。我从没这么近距离看过他那满脸坏疮的皮肤。
I should have said, "Yeah, I'm taking a whiz. What's it to you, gear head?" and just let him kill my butt. I coulda turned, and whizzed on him, and said "That answer your question, clutch mouth?" instead of swallowing and getting all clenched up with stage fright, so that he could finish first, zip up, and thump me in the back of the head, and say, "Well, I asked what you're doing, faggot."
我本该说：“是啊，我在撒尿。关你屁事，齿轮头？”然后让他把我打得半死。我本可以转过身，尿在他身上，说：“这能回答你的问题吗，离合器嘴？”而不是吞咽着，因为舞台恐惧症全身紧绷，让他抢先搞定，拉上拉链，对着我的后脑勺重重一击，说：“好吧，我问你在干嘛，娘娘腔。”
I should have spin dropped, and shoulder kicked him right in the face, and then pulled my dad's piece on him, and said, "How about I blow a big chunk of your brain right through the wall, butt wipe?" instead of letting him smack my head again and say, "You come in here again, and I'll kick your ass." And being so shook up that now I only use the faculty bathrooms and do a special swimming class with Ted Ludwig so I don't have to use the regular locker room.
我本该一个旋踢，一脚踹在他脸上，然后掏出我爸的家伙对着他，说：“你想让我把你的半个大脑从墙上喷出来吗，混蛋？”而不是让他再次重击我的头说：“你再敢进来，我就揍扁你。”我现在因为太害怕，只敢去教职员厕所，还要和泰德·路德维希上一门专门的游泳课，这样就不用去普通更衣室了。
My mother called my name. I waited a bit, then got up and went downstairs. My father looked through the screen door at my mother, and they smiled smug little smiles at each other. And I put my head down and ate as fast as I could. When my brother was done, he came in looking retarded and gloating at me.
我妈叫了我的名字。我等了一会儿，才下楼。我父亲透过纱门看着我母亲，他们相视一笑，笑得那般自鸣得意。我低着头，狼吞虎咽地吃起来。我弟弟吃完后，进来一脸痴呆样地对着我幸灾乐祸。
He got my sister to sing with him, "Hey, tubby tuba, why don't you cry, why don't you cry, why don't you cry?" A special song just for me. My mother said, "Now, kids." But my father allowed it, which made me almost start up with my crying again. I wasn't ashamed.
他让我妹妹和他一起唱：“嘿，大号桶，你怎么不哭，你怎么不哭，你怎么不哭？”一首专门为我准备的歌。我妈说：“好了，孩子们。”但我父亲默许了，这让我差点又要哭出来。我不感到羞耻。
That's when he really did it, got me out on the porch in front of the whole neighborhood and buzzed me good with grandpa's clippers. He buzzed me real good. I just sat there, stony-faced, and let him do it. The clumps of hair fell on my lap and down onto the concrete porch. I clamped my teeth together and stared at my father when he got in front of me to look at my hair and try to make it level.
就在这时，他真的这么做了，他把我在整个街坊邻居面前拉到门廊上，用爷爷的理发器狠狠地剪了我一通。他剪得非常彻底。我就坐在那里，面无表情，任由他摆布。一撮撮头发落在我腿上和水泥门廊上。我紧咬牙关，盯着我父亲，当他走到我面前审视我的头发并试图修剪整齐时。
He'd raise the clippers to try to cut a straight line, but his hands would shake like grandpa's. And I'd jerk my head just a little, so he'd get it wrong. But he couldn't admit he'd cut it wrong, so he'd go and do some little crap with the clippers as if there was more to be done. And then he'd come back to the front again and look at it like he was really going to do it. And I'd jerk it again. And after a while, the front wasn't an issue because it was gone.
他抬起理发器想剪出一条直线，但他的手像爷爷一样颤抖。我就故意轻微地晃动脑袋，让他弄错。但他不能承认剪坏了，所以他会用理发器做些无关紧要的修补，好像还有很多活儿没做完。然后他再回到前面，像真的要剪好一样看着它。我又晃了晃。过了一会儿，修剪前部已经没意义了，因为头发已经没剩多少了。
"All right," he said, "there you go." "Thanks a lot," I said, "great job." He grabbed my shirt. "You better watch your goddamned mouth," he said. "You've got no appreciation for anything your mother and I do around here." I made my face go blank 'til he let go. Then I went upstairs.
“好了，”他说，“这下行了。”“多谢了，”我说，“干得真漂亮。”他抓住我的衬衫。“你最好注意你那该死的嘴，”他说。“你一点都不懂我和你妈在这里做的一切。”我让脸部变得麻木直到他松开手。然后我上了楼。
My scalp looked like a giant fish belly in my mirror. I got to thinking about how to get out of school. But then I'd flunk my finals, and he'd wail me good for that. The next day was third-period lunch, and Holly would stop on the balcony to talk to Chris and me before going up the hill to hang out with Kenickie's people. Everything was pretty much wrecked.
镜子里的头皮看起来像个巨大的鱼肚皮。我开始想怎么逃学。但那样我就得挂科，他会为此狠狠揍我一顿。第二天是第三节课后的午餐时间，霍莉本会停在阳台上和克里斯及我说话，然后再上山去和肯尼基那帮人混在一起。一切基本都被毁了。
I was lying there for a long time. And eventually, I got an idea how to get them all back. I would set my alarm for 3:00 AM. I would go into the basement and get grandpa's clippers. In the dead of night, I would take the rest of my hair off, take it right down to the bone, and make it like sandpaper.
我躺了很久。最终，我想到一个报复他们的主意。我把闹钟定在凌晨3点。我会去地下室拿爷爷的理发器。在深夜，我会把剩下的头发全剪掉，剪到露骨头，弄得像砂纸一样。
In the morning, I could just see it. My brother's eyes would be out of his head. "Whoa," he'd say, "radical." I would stare at him with an ugly look. My mother would walk into the kitchen and say, "Oh my god, oh my god, what happened?" I wouldn't say a word. My dad would be grinding his molars, seeing his handiwork down the tube.
到了早上，我都能想象那场景。我弟弟的眼睛肯定会瞪出来。“哇，”他会说，“太激进了。”我会用丑陋的眼神瞪他。我妈走进厨房会说：“噢我的天哪，噢我的天哪，发生了什么？”我一个字也不会说。我爸会磨着后槽牙，看着他的杰作付诸东流。
"Whoo-hee," my brother would say, "holy geez, whoo-hee." My mother would follow me around and say, "Do you want to talk? This isn't like you. What's happened to you? You're frightening us." I'd walk to the door and shut it behind me. I wouldn't be going on the bus. I would have all my money and my dad's piece in my pocket. And I would not be going on the bus.
“喔——嘿，”我弟弟会说，“天哪，喔——嘿。”我妈会跟在我身后说：“你想谈谈吗？你不是这样的。你怎么了？你吓到我们了。”我会走到门口把门关上。我不会去挤校车。我会把所有的钱和我爸的家伙揣在口袋里。我不会去挤校车。
I woke up. It was morning. My father's head was in the door. "Get up," he said, "you're going to miss school." My mom called up about the bus coming.
我醒了。已经是早上了。我父亲的头探进了门。“起床，”他说，“你要迟到了。”我妈在下面喊校车要来了。
I waited, then got up and went downstairs. My brother said, "Later, buzzy," and hid behind her, so I couldn't thump him. On the bus, the older kids were pinging the back of my head, making lawn mower and army and male pattern baldness jokes. I could hear them in the back. I was trying to laugh like I thought it was funny. You couldn't say anything to kids like them.
我等了一会儿，下楼去了。我弟弟说：“回头见，秃子，”然后躲在他妈身后，这样我就没法揍他。在校车上，高年级的孩子敲着我的后脑勺，开着关于除草机、军队和男性秃顶的玩笑。我能听到他们在后面笑。我试着像觉得好笑一样跟着笑。你没法跟他们那样的孩子讲理。
All day long, Sanford was dogging on me, rubbing my head and laughing. After a while, I didn't care so much. But at lunch, Holly came up and stood next to Sanford and me on the balcony, her long, yellow hair and throaty laugh, the smell of tobacco. My tongue was thick as steak.
一整天，桑福德都在折磨我，揉着我的头大笑。过了一会儿，我没那么在意了。但在午餐时，霍莉走过来站在桑福德和我身边的阳台上，她那金色的长发，沙哑的笑声，还有烟草味。我的舌头僵硬得像块牛排。
She was looking down on the parking lot dumpsters. I knew what she was thinking, what a total doink I was, that I must have wanted my hair this way, like I went to a barber and asked for it because it's my idea of a good haircut. Inside, she was barfing. My only chance was to explain what he did to me. I was shaking.
她俯视着停车场的垃圾箱。我知道她在想什么，想我是个彻头彻尾的笨蛋，想我一定是因为想要这种发型，就像我特意去理发店要求的，因为这是我觉得最好的发型。在内心深处，她觉得恶心透了。我唯一的希望是解释他对我做了什么。我全身发抖。
I said, "My father cut my hair. I'm so bummed." I could hear myself talking like a spaz. She wasn't even looking. I said, "It looks like total crap. There was nothing I could do. Can you believe it? What a nightmare."
我说：“我爸剪了我的头发。我难受死了。”我能听见自己说话像个怪胎。她甚至没看我。我说：“它看起来糟透了。我一点办法也没有。你敢信吗？简直是个噩梦。”
She looked at me like she just realized that I was there. She said, "Huh, I didn't notice." Just like that. "Huh, I didn't notice." It hit me with a soft thud in the solar plextum.
她看着我，仿佛刚意识到我的存在。她说：“哈，我没注意。”就这么简单。“哈，我没注意。”这句话像沉重的闷击打在我的心窝上。
We stood there looking out over the Dumpsters, where the kids were throwing milk cartons at each other. I was fighting the feeling, but it kept getting bigger. The whole shape of life was crushing down flat into nothing. I could feel it shoving me right out of view until I was nowhere, I was so squashed.
我们站在那儿望着垃圾箱，孩子们在那儿互相投掷牛奶盒。我在抵御那种情绪，但它不断膨胀。整个生活的轮廓都被压扁成了虚无。我能感觉到它把我推向无人可见之处，直到我消失不见，我被压得太扁了。
Down below, a kid got pelted with an exploding milk. It happened in a movie-ish way. Holly laughed and squeezed Chris's arm. Everyone was laughing except me. A couple of motor heads, who were hill-hauling a seventh grader to grass stain his shirt, let him go and came down to see what would happen.
在下面，一个孩子被炸开的牛奶击中了。那场景像电影里的一样。霍莉笑了，挤了挤克里斯的手臂。每个人都在笑，除了我。几个机车狂，正拖着一个七年级生往草地上蹭，想弄脏他的衬衫，他们放开他，走过来看看发生了什么。
The milked kid was trying to smile, but you could see him swallowing. He knew he just became the kid who got hit with an exploding milk. For maybe three days, that's who he would be.
那个被牛奶弄脏的孩子试图微笑，但你可以看到他在吞咽。他知道自己刚才成了那个被爆炸牛奶击中的倒霉蛋。大概三天之内，他都会是那个“倒霉蛋”。
He would go home tonight, and his mother would say, "Where'd you get all that mess on your shirt?" And he'd say, "It wasn't my fault. A kid threw it at me." And his father would say, "Did you punch him out?" And he'd say, "You can't just punch kids out." And the father would say, "I woulda punched his lights right out for him." And the kid would be thinking, "Sure, I bet."
他今晚回家，他母亲会问：“你衬衫上怎么搞成这样？”他说：“不是我的错。有个孩子扔的。”他父亲会说：“你把他揍了一顿没？”他说：“你不能随便揍人。”父亲会说：“我要是你就把他揍个半死。”孩子心里会想：“当然，我敢打赌。”
I was holding my teeth together. The feeling was getting bigger than me. Holly stood up tall to see over the Dumpster edge. I was a midget next to her.
我紧咬着牙。那种感觉变得比我还巨大。霍莉站得笔直，想看清垃圾箱边缘的情况。在她旁边，我像个侏儒。
The exploding milk kid walked up to a little seventh grader who was laughing and said something to him. You could see the littler kid saying he didn't throw the milk and looking toward two other big kids who had been throwing milks. But the exploding milk kid was already in the little kid's face, pushing him. The milked kid's friend walked up behind the littler kid.
那个被牛奶弄脏的孩子走到一个正在笑的七年级生面前，说了些什么。你可以看到那个更小的孩子说不是他扔的牛奶，并看向另外两个一直在扔牛奶的大孩子。但那个被弄脏的孩子已经凑到那个小孩子面前，推搡着他。被弄脏的那个孩子的朋友走到那个小孩子背后。
He pulled a can out of his pocket and pointed it at him. "Whoa," Sanford said, "he's macing him. Awesome." The seventh grader walked backward, holding his face. He tripped on the curb. The milked kid pushed him all the way down and started kicking him in his face and in the stomach.
他从口袋里掏出一个喷雾罐对着他。“哇，”桑福德说，“他要喷他了。太牛了。”七年级生捂着脸向后走去。他在路缘石上绊倒了。那个被弄脏的孩子把他推倒在地，开始踢他的脸和肚子。
"Oh my god," Holly said. She put her hand to mouth, watching. I could see her face. She was half-smiling, watching the blood pouring out of the kid's face. She grabbed Chris's arm. "This is major," Sanford said.
“天哪，”霍莉说。她用手捂住嘴看着。我能看到她的表情。她在半笑，看着鲜血从孩子的脸上流出。她抓住了克里斯的手臂。“这太严重了，”桑福德说。
Everyone stopped to watch. You could see Kenickie's people starting down the hill. I kept waiting for the teachers to run out and stop it before the little kid got hurt any worse. The milked kid was still kicking him. There was blood on his sneaker.
每个人都停下来观看。你可以看到肯尼基的人正走下山坡。我一直在等老师跑出来在那个小孩子受更重伤之前制止这一切。那个被弄脏的孩子还在踢他。他的运动鞋上有血。
The other kid wasn't moving at all or grunting like before. "Jesus," said Sanford. The milked kid kicked him one more time in the back, then stopped. He licked his lips and looked around. His friend grabbed his sleeve, and they started toward the hill.
另一个孩子完全不动了，也不像刚才那样发出声音。“耶稣啊，”桑福德说。那个被弄脏的孩子在他背上又踢了一脚，然后停了下来。他舔了舔嘴唇，四下张望。他的朋友抓着他的袖子，他们开始往山坡上走。
I couldn't help it. I was crying right there in front of everyone. I took a step backward and turned toward the wall. I could see Holly looking at me when I sat down. I was crying hard, and I knew Sanford and her were staring at me. But there was nothing I could do about it. I couldn't stop it anymore.
我忍不住了。我就在大家面前哭了出来。我向后退了一步，转身对着墙。当我坐下时，我能感觉到霍莉在看我。我哭得很厉害，我知道桑福德和她在盯着我。但我无能为力。我再也止不住了。
Tim Melley is an associate professor of English at the mysteriously-named University of Miami of Ohio. His story, "My Crap Life," first appeared in The Sun.
蒂姆·梅利是俄亥俄州名为“迈阿密大学”的副教授。他的故事《我那糟糕的生活》首次发表在《太阳报》上。
Well, coming up, anatomy of a public radio feature story shot to hell because an insider became an outsider. And life among the Christians. In a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
好吧，接下来，一个公共广播专题报道因圈内人变成圈外人而毁掉的故事，以及基督徒的生活。在来自国际公共广播电台的节目继续之后，稍后回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you all sorts of different stories on that theme. Today's program, One Of Us. Stories of outsiders who want to be insiders and insiders who want to be outsiders.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选定一个主题，为你带来各种各样的相关故事。今天的节目主题是“我们中的一员”。关于那些想成为圈内人的圈外人，以及那些想成为圈外人的圈内人。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program, in which we move from fiction to nonfiction, from adolescence to adulthood, from social life to work life. Because any workplace of any size at all has its insiders and outsiders, its own rules and codes that determine how you move from one group to another. Those rules and codes are usually very arcane, of course. It's Byzantine. At the Mercantile Exchange, for example, here in Chicago, where guys stand on the trading floor, yelling prices and bids for pork bellies and cattle options, a trader named Mike Quattrocki explained the rules of the floor to me. They include things like--
我们来到了节目的第二幕，我们将从虚构转向非虚构，从青春期转向成年，从社交生活转向工作生活。因为任何规模的职场都有其圈内人和圈外人，有其决定你如何从一个群体转入另一个群体的规则和准则。当然，这些规则和准则通常非常晦涩。这就像拜占庭帝国一样复杂。例如，在芝加哥的商业交易所，人们站在交易大厅里，为猪肉大排和牛只期权报价，交易员麦克·夸特罗基向我解释了场内规则。其中包括——
Say I'm bidding on a thing-- or I'm offering something, and someone offers it one fraction of a price better than me and gets the whole trade, that's called "carping a trade." So they carp your market. They take the whole trade. You're like, "Well, I was just a fraction of a price away. Don't I deserve something?" Technically speaking, no. You deserve nothing. Your price wasn't good enough. The best offer is the best offer. The best bid is the best bid. So they take your trade.
比如说我正在竞标某样东西——或者我正在提供什么东西，有人以比我更好的价格优势抢走了整个交易，这就叫“截胡”。他们截胡了你的行情。他们拿走了整个交易。你就像在说：“嘿，我只差一点点价格。我就不配得到一点份额吗？”从技术上讲，不。你不配得到任何东西。你的价格不够好。最好的报价就是最好的报价。最好的投标就是最好的投标。所以他们拿走了你的交易。
What am I gonna do to you next time if you've stolen a trade from me? Or I perceive that you've taken this trade by carping my market? I'm gonna try and carp your market.
如果你从我手里抢走了一笔交易，我下次会怎么对你？或者我认为你通过截胡我的行情抢走了这笔交易？我会尝试截胡你的行情。
Guys who carp markets do not stay insiders very long. Well, this next story is about two people in two different kinds of jobs with two different sets of codes. Dan Collison is a public radio reporter whose stories are usually in places like All Things Considered. He did a series where he rode across the country on a Greyhound bus, did stories about the people he met along the way. And a while back, he set out to do a kind of quintessential public radio feature story, a story about the working man. And it all fell apart, all because the working man decided, in this case, that he was not one of them.
喜欢截胡的人在圈内待不了太久。好吧，下一个故事是关于两个从事不同工作、遵循不同准则的人。丹·柯林森是一位公共广播记者，他的故事通常出现在《万事皆有因》等栏目。他曾制作过一系列专题，骑着灰狗巴士横穿全国，讲述沿途遇到的人的故事。不久前，他着手制作一个典型的公共广播专题报道，一个关于工人的故事。结果一切都搞砸了，全因为工人们在这次事件中认定，他不是“他们的一员”。
Pilottown, Louisiana, is the last town on the Mississippi River. It's about 90 miles south of New Orleans, beyond the end of the road. You have to take a boat to get there. Pilottown is built entirely on stilts in order to keep the houses above the marshy swamps. There are only 16 year-round residents of Pilottown.
路易斯安那州的皮洛特敦是密西西比河上的最后一个城镇。它位于新奥尔良以南约90英里，在公路的尽头之外。你必须乘船才能到达那里。皮洛特敦完全建在木桩上，以便让房屋高出沼泽地。皮洛特敦全职居民只有16人。
As the name suggests, the pilots are the reason the town exists. They are an elite group of men who climb rope ladders-- they're called Jacob's Ladders-- up the sides of massive freighters and tankers. Their job is to navigate the ships through treacherous, narrow straits, around dredges and supertankers, and over sandbars, to and from the Gulf of Mexico. It's like threading the eye of a needle.
正如名字所暗示的那样，领航员就是这个小镇存在的原因。他们是一个精英群体，顺着绳梯——被称为“雅各布梯”——爬上巨大的货轮和油轮。他们的工作是引导船只通过危险、狭窄的海峡，绕过挖泥船和超级油轮，并越过沙洲，往返于墨西哥湾。这就像针尖穿线。
I've always wanted to be a pilot. I can remember just being awestruck by the whole idea of it.
我一直想成为一名领航员。我还记得被这个想法彻底震撼的感觉。
The first interviews I did were with two young apprentice pilots. This is where things began to unravel. Ever since the Pilots' Association was formed back in 1899, fathers have passed on their jobs to their sons. As a result, there's never been a pilot who was not a white male. Without any prompting, one of the apprentices informed me that this "nepotism," his word, will soon be a thing of the past.
我做的第一次采访是与两名年轻的领航员学徒进行的。事情就是从这里开始失控的。自1899年领航员协会成立以来，父亲们就一直把工作传给儿子。结果，从未有过一名领航员不是白人男性。在没有任何提示的情况下，其中一名学徒告诉我，这种“裙带关系”（他的用词）很快就会成为过去式。
Times are changing. So hopefully, we might be one of the last groups to through here in the same process that the pilots have used for 100 years. Nepotism might be on the way out.
时代在变。所以希望，我们可能是最后一批通过领航员100年来所使用的那种流程进入这里的人。裙带关系可能即将终结。
I dutifully followed up with a couple questions. "Would there ever come a day," I asked, "when women and minorities would be admitted into the Association?" Here, I had unwittingly wandered into a hornet's nest. Turns out, the pilots are a little touchy about this. I found out later that the NAACP is threatening to file a lawsuit unless the Pilots' Association opens things up to African-Americans.
我尽职尽责地跟进了几个问题。“是否有那么一天，”我问，“女性和少数族裔会被准许加入协会？”在这里，我无意中闯进了马蜂窝。事实证明，领航员们对这个问题很敏感。我后来发现，除非领航员协会对非裔美国人开放，否则全国有色人种协进会威胁要提起诉讼。
It's a life that a lot of people think they might like, but wouldn't. I think you have to grow up with it.
这是一种很多人以为自己会喜欢，但其实不然的生活。我想你必须从小就在这种环境中长大。
That's Gary Mott, recorded before he hated my guts. He's been a pilot for 30 years.
那位是加里·莫特，在他讨厌我之前录下的。他当领航员已经30年了。
My father was a pilot. And so was his father. I'm third generation.
我父亲是领航员。他父亲也是。我是第三代。
The morning after I interviewed him and the apprentices, Mott confronted me outside the pilots' headquarters. He's short and muscular and has piercing, dark eyes. He's not a guy you want to get angry, but that's just what he was. He had apparently talked to the apprentices about their interview and had somehow concluded that I was in Pilottown to dig up dirt.
采访他和学徒后的第二天早上，莫特在领航员总部外与我对质。他个子不高，肌肉发达，有一双锐利的深色眼睛。他不是你想惹毛的那种人，但这正是他当时的状态。他显然已经和学徒谈过他们的采访，并不知怎么地断定我是来皮洛特敦挖黑料的。
"Who do you think you are?" he screamed, "Coming down here to stir things up, calling us a white males club?" When I explained that the issue of diversity among the pilots, or the lack thereof, was not the focus of my story, and that one of the apprentices had brought up the matter of nepotism in the first place, it only made matters worse. That apprentice, it turns out, was Gary Mott's son. He stalked off, angrier than ever.
“你以为你是谁？”他吼道，“跑来这里搅浑水，说我们是白人俱乐部？”当我解释说领航员的多样性问题——或其缺乏——并不是我故事的重点，而且是学徒自己先提到裙带关系的，这反而让情况变得更糟了。事实证明，那个学徒正是加里·莫特的儿子。他愤怒地走开了，比以往任何时候都更生气。
From then on, every time I would walk into a room of pilots, they'd stop talking. At first, I thought I might be imagining it. But it happened each time. I ate a lot of meals by myself. When the pilots did talk to me, it was to ask when I was planning to leave.
从那时起，每当我走进领航员所在的房间，他们就会停止交谈。起初，我还以为是我多心了。但每次都这样。我吃了很多顿独食。当领航员们和我说话时，也只是问我打算什么时候离开。
One day, in the pilot's TV lounge, I decided to break the silence. "Look, you guys have to believe me. I'm not out to make you look bad." "But we don't even know who you are," they countered. "You could be anybody." It was true. I could have been anybody. All I had was my radio gear and an old business card from a video company I had worked for until it folded.
有一天，在领航员的电视休息室里，我决定打破沉默。“看，你们得相信我。我不是要把你们描绘得那么糟糕。”“但我们甚至不知道你是谁，”他们反驳道。“你可能是任何人。”是真的。我确实可能是任何人。我有的只有我的录音设备，和一张我以前工作的视频公司的旧名片。
My assurances that I was a legitimate reporter fell on deaf ears. The more I tried to explain, the guiltier I seemed.
我作为一名合法记者的保证被当作了耳边风。我越试图解释，我看起来就越像有罪。
Word of my incursion had reached all the way down to the pilots' outpost in the Gulf of Mexico, where the radio dispatcher, who looked like Doctor John in cut-offs and was said to practice voodoo in the French quarter, asked me if I was with the Congressional Black Caucus.
我闯入的消息已经传到了他们在墨西哥湾的领航员前哨站，那里的无线电调度员——看起来像剪掉裤腿的约翰医生，据说在法国区练习巫毒教——问我是否是国会黑人核心小组成员。
What complicated things further was that my host, the pilot who had smoothed the way for my visit, a genial fellow named Mac Lincoln, was caught in the middle. He tried to vouch for me, but he couldn't promise the other pilots that I wouldn't sully their image in some way. If I portrayed them as a white males club, as they feared, Mac would take the heat. He pleaded with me on numerous occasions as a friend, man to man. "Don't touch the racial thing. Then you can come back to Pilottown."
让情况更复杂的是，我的主人，那个为我的访问铺平道路的领航员，一位叫麦克·林肯的亲切伙伴，夹在中间很难做。他试图为我担保，但他无法向其他领航员保证我不会在某种程度上玷污他们的形象。如果我像他们担心的那样把他们描绘成一个白人男性俱乐部，麦克就会遭殃。他曾多次以朋友的身份，男人对男人地请求我。“别碰种族那个话题。那样你就能回到皮洛特敦。”
I'd come to Pilottown in the first place to let the outside world know about one of the few romantic professions left in America. Mark Twain put it this way, "A pilot was one of the only unfettered and entirely independent human beings that lived on the earth." Now these unfettered and independent human beings agreed on one thing. I'd come to destroy their way of life. I was the enemy all because of an issue I hadn't even raised.
我当初来到皮洛特敦，是为了让外面的世界知道这个美国仅存的浪漫职业之一。马克·吐温曾这样形容：“领航员是地球上仅有的无拘无束、完全独立的个体之一。”现在这些无拘无束、独立的个体达成了一致。我来是要毁掉他们的生活方式。我成了敌人，仅仅因为一个我甚至没提过的问题。
Everything was going wrong. An old pilot with lots of great tales to tell wouldn't return my phone calls. The 83-year-old postmistress of Pilottown wouldn't talk to me. And the president of the Pilots' Association even called down from New Orleans to see what I was up to. On top of that, because of some bad luck with the pilots' schedule, I had to wait several days to go out on a ship with Mac Lincoln.
一切都搞砸了。一位有许多精彩故事可讲的老领航员不回我的电话。皮洛特敦83岁的邮政局长不跟我说话。领航员协会的会长甚至从新奥尔良打电话来打听我在干什么。最糟糕的是，由于领航员日程安排上的运气不好，我不得不等好几天才能和麦克·林肯一起出海。
So while I waited, I wandered around outside and collected sound, the river lapping against the dock, the hum of ships rolling by, river birds chirping, insects buzzing. I collected hours of noises, enough to start a small sound effects library. I even tried to record some fiddler crabs scurrying back into their holes. I didn't have much else to do.
所以我在等待的时候，在外面四处走动收集声音：河水拍打码头的声音，船只经过的嗡嗡声，河鸟的鸣叫，昆虫的振翅。我收集了数小时的噪音，足够建立一个小型的音效库了。我甚至尝试录制一些提琴蟹钻回洞里的声音。我没别的事情可做。
Finally, I got my chance to climb aboard a ship. It was sometime after midnight. In the moonlight, I could just make out the silhouette of a giant Greek tanker plowing toward us.
终于，我有机会登上一艘船了。那是午夜之后。在月光下，我隐约能看到一艘巨大的希腊油轮正犁水向我们驶来。
As we left the dock in the transport boat, I overheard on my headphones the boat operator picked up by Mac's wireless microphone. "What is he doing here? Is he gonna get on that ship?" So much for Southern hospitality. I was about to climb up the side of a huge moving tanker on a wobbly rope ladder, and I was scared.
当我们乘交通艇离开码头时，我通过耳机听到船员收到了麦克无线麦克风的信号。“他在干嘛？他要上那艘船吗？”这就是所谓的南方好客之道。我就要顺着晃动的绳梯爬上一艘巨大的正在移动的油轮侧面，我吓坏了。
I knew how important the boat operator was to the upcoming maneuver. The ship doesn't slow down. The smaller boat has to pull up alongside it, so we can grab the ladder that's dangling over the side. It's like scaling up a giant steel wall hundreds of feet high, as it rocks back and forth.
我知道船员对即将到来的操纵有多重要。船不会减速。小船必须靠在它旁边，这样我们才能抓住悬在侧面的梯子。这就像爬上一面高数百英尺、随着波浪来回摇晃的巨大钢墙。
A wrong move by the boat operator and I could fall between the two vessels. A number of experienced pilots have died this way. It was ludicrous and paranoid to think about foul play, but it did cross my mind. If I fell to my death, who would know? Any clues on my audiotapes would be shredded in the ship's rudder blade. I didn't want to think what would happen to me.
船员操作失误，我可能会掉进两艘船之间。不少经验丰富的领航员就是这样丧命的。认为有人想加害我是荒谬和多疑的，但这确实在我脑海中闪过。如果我摔死，谁会知道？我录音带上的任何线索都会被船的舵叶搅碎。我不想去想我会发生什么。
Be sure you don't fall off. That river's ice cold.
一定要抓稳，别掉下去。那河水冰冷刺骨。
I climb up the rope ladder, one sweaty hand over the other, shins banging against the wood slats, the river roaring below. I'm fearing for my life.
我爬上绳梯，一手抓过另一只满是汗水的手，小腿撞击着木条，脚下河水奔腾。我为自己的性命感到恐惧。
Hold on.
抓稳了。
I got into radio because there are millions of people whose stories are never told. This is where you end up when some of them would rather keep it that way.
我进入广播界是因为有数百万人，他们的故事从未被讲述。这就是当其中一些人宁愿保守秘密时，你最终会面临的境地。
Dan Collison.
丹·柯林森。
Act Three, My Church Life. So Susan Bergman wrote a book in which she mentioned her own Christianity. And a while after the book was published, out of the blue, she got a call from someone who told her that she had been chosen as one of the top 50 young Christians under 40, under 40 years old, that is.
第三幕，“我的教会生活”。苏珊·伯格曼写了一本书，书中提到了她自己的基督教信仰。书出版后不久，意想不到的事情发生了，她接到一个电话，对方告诉她，她被选为50名“40岁以下青年基督徒”之一，40岁以下。
Making a list like this is a sort of odd publicity stunt for a major world religion. It's the kind of thing that People magazine does to boost circulation. They name the 10 best-dressed people in America or the 10 sexiest men. Something a rotary club in a middle-sized American suburb or city might do to ensure attendance at a charity dinner. It seems, I don't know, beneath Christianity. Christianity, which built Middle Europe, which has the Gospels, and the letter of Paul, and the Vatican.
制作这样一个榜单对于一个主要的世界性宗教来说，是一种奇怪的公关噱头。这就像《人物》杂志为了增加销量而做的某种东西。他们选出美国最会穿衣的10个人或最性感的10个男人。这更像是某个中等城市或城镇的扶轮社为了确保慈善晚宴的出席率而做的事情。这似乎——我不确定——有损基督教的尊严。基督教，那个建立了中欧，拥有《福音书》、保罗书信和梵蒂冈的宗教。
Susan, needless to say, did not know how to respond. This is the story of how she allowed herself to be included when this particular group of Christians pointed at her and said, "You're one of us."
不用说，苏珊不知道该如何回应。这就是她如何允许自己被接纳的故事，当这个特殊的基督徒群体指着她说，“你是我们中的一员”时。
"You're on our list," says the woman's voice on my message machine, a freelance writer for Christianity Today. "Would there be a time I could interview you for a profile?" She calls back, this time with a deadline.
“你在我们的名单上，”我的语音信箱里传来一个女人的声音，她是《今日基督教》的一位自由撰稿人。“有时间采访你吗？”她又打来电话，这次带了截稿日期。
"Tell me about the list," I say, immediately uncomfortable with the idea. "50 people under 40 years old, evangelical up-and-comers," she tells me. They're inviting all 50 of us to the convention of the National Association of Evangelicals in Orlando. We can get to know each other there. "Is Ralph Reed on the list?" I ask.
“告诉我这个名单，”我说，立刻对这个想法感到不舒服。“50个40岁以下的人，福音派的后起之秀，”她告诉我。他们邀请我们50人全部参加在奥兰多举行的全国福音派协会会议。我们可以在那里互相了解。“拉尔夫·里德在名单上吗？”我问。
Though I call myself a Christian, I don't call myself part of the religious right. "I dare to believe," a friend says, "that when Jesus invites all who labor and are heavy-laden, he's not screening for HIV, or voting behavior, or asking whether or not someone has had a divorce, or an abortion." The woman on the other end of the line doesn't understand my hesitation. "You're not an evangelical?" she asks. "What are you, then?" "This is a pretty big question. I'll have to think about how to answer that one too. Can I call you back?"
虽然我称自己为基督徒，但我并不认为自己是宗教右翼的一员。“我敢相信，”一个朋友说，“当耶稣邀请所有劳苦担重担的人时，他并没有筛选艾滋病、投票行为，或者询问某人是否离过婚或做过堕胎。”电话那头的女人不理解我的犹豫。“你不是福音派吗？”她问。“那你是哪种人？”“这是一个很大的问题。我也得考虑如何回答。我能回给你吗？”
I walk out of the steamy balm of an Orlando morning into the refrigerated conference center across the street from Universal Studios. I follow the signs to registration. The lady taking names can't find mine. "Who are you with, dear?" The lady asks pleasantly. I look at her, puzzled. I'm standing there by myself.
我走出了奥兰多清晨闷热的空气，进入了环球影城对面冷气十足的会议中心。我顺着指示牌去注册。负责登记的女士找不到我的名字。“你和谁一起来的，亲爱的？”她愉快地问。我困惑地看着她。我是一个人站在那儿。
I look around for someone I might know. "Are you a pastor's wife?" she smiles, innocent of her assumptions. "I'm under 40," I hear myself say, against my will, as if offering a secret handshake. "Oh, with the group of you," she nods knowingly and types my first name only onto my badge.
我环顾四周，看看有没有熟人。“你是牧师的妻子吗？”她微笑着，对我一无所知。我不由自主地听到自己说：“我不到40岁，”仿佛在提供某种秘密接头暗号。“噢，是那组人，”她会意地点点头，在我的名牌上只打上了我的名字。
The main meeting of the day is already underway when I find the auditorium full of what looks to be mostly 58- to 61-year-old, liver-spotted, silver-haired men. I look around me. No wonder someone thought they needed to make a list. Among the 800 or so leaders of this loose association of 48 Protestant denominations which have gathered for their annual convention, only 30 or so look like they might have been born after 1957. At various times in the proceedings, they ask everyone on the list to stand up, so that the crowd can take a look for a moment, as if to glimpse what the future may hold.
当我发现礼堂里坐满了大部分看起来像58到61岁、长着老年斑、银发苍苍的男人们时，当天的主要会议已经开始了。我环顾四周。难怪有人觉得有必要列个清单。在这48个新教教派的松散联盟中，800多名领导人齐聚在这里参加年度会议，只有30人看起来像是1957年以后出生的。在会议的各个环节中，他们要求名单上的所有人都站起来，让观众看上一眼，仿佛是为了窥见未来可能掌握在谁手中。
Ted Haggard, one of the people on the list, a young preacher from Colorado Springs, who pastors his church of over 6,000 members, is talking animatedly about prayer. Not only did his church decide that they would pray for every person in their city, they took out maps, and assigned districts, and organized teams broken into pairs who walked and prayed in front of the houses of the people they prayed for. When they had done this, the next year, they decided to mail out letters, letting people know they were praying with a reply card that could be sent back with a request, so that the prayer could be more relevant. Thousands of cards came back with a question, a weakness, a personal need. So they keep on praying, he says, drawing a simple diagram of the plan on an easel board.
泰德·哈格德，榜单上的人之一，来自科罗拉多斯普林斯的年轻传教士，他管理的教会拥有超过6000名成员，正生动地谈论着祈祷。他的教会不仅决定为城里的每个人祈祷，他们还拿出地图，分配区域，组织了两人一组的团队，在他们祈祷的人家门前走过并进行祈祷。做完这些后，第二年，他们决定寄出信件，让人们知道他们正在为对方祈祷，并附上一张回复卡，以便祈祷内容能更贴切。成千上万张卡片寄了回来，上面写着问题、弱点、个人需求。所以他继续祈祷，并在画板上画出了该计划的简单示意图。
"Susan!" I hear someone call. Who knows I'm here? "David?" It's the tall, gangly kid who ran the pig roasts in college. Same guy, same shock of blond hair falling to one side, same hospitable skill set that got him his current job organizing this conference and hosting meetings of the 50 under 40 while we're in Orlando. He instantly becomes my inside source, my orienteer.
“苏珊！”我听到有人喊。谁知道我在这？“大卫？”那是大学里负责烤猪肉的那位高瘦小子。还是那个人，还是那缕垂到一边的金色头发，还是那种好客的技能，让他得到了现在这份工作：组织这次会议，并在我们待在奥兰多期间主持50名40岁以下人士的会议。他立刻成了我的内线、我的向导。
"What exactly do evangelicals believe?" I want to know. "We have drafts of resolutions," he hands me a stack of papers. "One of the resolutions they're considering poses the question, does God speak in our time."
“福音派到底相信什么？”我想知道。“我们有决议草案，”他递给我一叠文件。“他们正在考虑的一项决议提出了一个问题：上帝在我们的时代说话吗？”
I asked for a word from God once. Just one. When I prayed, I felt, as everyone must have who has tried to pray, that God was silent. I was lying face down on the floor in my office. "One word, please, God. Answer me," which is a presumptuous demand, I know, to propose, even in a gentle way, that the creator of the universe bend his lips to my ear and speak.
我曾经请求上帝给一个启示。哪怕一次。当我祈祷时，我感觉到，就像每一个尝试祈祷的人一样，上帝是沉默的。我趴在办公室的地板上。“一个字，拜托，上帝。回答我，”我知道这是一个傲慢的要求，甚至提出这种要求，即使以温和的方式，也意味着让宇宙的创造者弯下身子对我的耳朵说话。
Yet, isn't this what Elijah did, asking God to light his altar on fire after he doused it with water? It worked for Elijah. The fire of the Lord fell and consumed the burnt offering, and the wood, and the stones, and the dust, and licked up the water that was in the trench. When the people saw the fire, they fell on their faces and said, "The Lord, he is God. The Lord, he is God." I believe that God still speaks in this way. On the floor in my office that day, the word that came into my head was "garden," the very word I needed at that moment.
然而，以利亚不是也这样做吗？他在祭坛上浇了水后，请求上帝让祭坛起火。这对以利亚奏效了。主的火降下，烧尽了燔祭、木头、石头、尘土，又舔干了沟里的水。人们看到火时，俯伏在地说：“主是上帝，主是上帝。”我相信上帝至今仍以这种方式说话。那天在办公室的地板上，我脑子里出现的字是“花园”，那正是那一刻我需要的字。
It's Bike Week at Daytona, only a short drive from here. 300,000 bikers standing around under big, old tents, I imagine, in their muscle shirts. They steam, while we freeze. They've come from all over the country, as do most conventioneers, because this is the one group, the something larger than themselves, to which they feel comfortable belonging. Some of us under 40, I imagine, are secretly thinking about checking out the bikes after lunch.
这里离代托纳的摩托车周只有很短的车程。我想象着30万名骑手穿着背心站在巨大的旧帐篷下。他们汗流浃背，而我们却冷得发抖。他们来自全国各地，就像大多数参加会议的人一样，因为这是一个群体，是比他们自身更伟大的东西，让他们感到自在。我想，我们这些40岁以下的人中，有些人可能正暗自想着午餐后去看看那些摩托车。
There must be a uniform there, as there is here among the evangelicals. A suit and tie, affordable shoes, a presidential smile. There must be a preferred salutation.
那里肯定也有制服，就像这里福音派中间有的一样。西装领带，买得起的鞋子，总统式的微笑。肯定也有首选的问候语。
I overhear this scenario more than once when pastors who haven't seen each other for a year reacquaint themselves. They pat each other on the shoulder. "Rich, so good to see you." "Barry, how are you doing, brother?" Extended grip of right hands.
当一年没见面的牧师重新叙旧时，我不止一次听到这样的场景。他们拍着对方的肩膀。“里奇，见到你真高兴。”“巴里，兄弟，你怎么样？”右手紧紧握在一起。
"Very well, thanks. God is good. We're seeing about 900 on a Sunday morning." "Two services?" Now Rich's smile tightens. Barry nods, "Thinking about going to a third."
“很好，谢谢。上帝是善良的。我们周日早上大约有900人参加礼拜。”“做两次礼拜吗？”现在里奇的笑容紧绷了。巴里点点头，“在考虑做第三次。”
Barry and Rich, like others of the pastors here, think of people as souls. They like to count, to speak of their success in the evangelically-correct paradigm of rising attendance on Sunday morning. One of the earthly rewards they have discovered for the hard, people-intensive jobs they have is to compare the size of their ranks and their building programs with that of their seminary roommates.
巴里和里奇，像这里其他牧师一样，把人看作灵魂。他们喜欢数数，喜欢在周日早上参会人数增加的“福音派正确”范式中谈论他们的成功。他们为这些人密集的工作所发现的世俗奖励之一，就是与神学院的室友比较他们的规模和建筑计划。
Road warriors. Soldiers of Christ. What would it be like, I wonder, to combine the two conventions under one vast tent? To count the bikers and the non-bikers together? What greeting would we use? Who would more graciously welcome the other?
公路上的战士。基督的士兵。我想，如果把这两个会议合并在一个巨大的帐篷下会是什么样子？把骑手和非骑手放在一起计数？我们会用什么问候语？谁会更慷慨地欢迎对方？
Three o'clock, the younger folks are supposed to meet in a room together to discuss the state of Christian affairs. Tables have been pushed together. An empty glass for water, a pencil, and three index cards have been placed in front of every participant. 20 or so people sit at the table, the ones on the list who could make it.
下午3点，年轻人应该聚在一个房间里讨论基督教事务的状况。桌子被推到了一起。桌子前面放着空水杯、铅笔和三张索引卡。桌旁坐着20人左右，那是榜单上能赶过来的人。
Around the edge of the room, someone has lined up chairs for those interested in observing, though not participating, it's made clear, with the group under 40. Some reporters, a publisher, organization heads line the walls. There's evidently not going to be any cross-pollination of the old with the new.
在房间边缘，有人给那些有兴趣观察但不参与的人摆好了椅子，很明确地说明了这些观察员不能参与40岁以下的小组。一些记者、出版商、机构负责人沿着墙壁站着。显然，老一辈和新一代之间不会有交叉交流。
Star Parker introduces herself. "I'm a former welfare mom," she says. That was then. Now she helps run a social policy research center she helped found with funds from her successful ad agency. Here's David Gushee, an ethics professor, who drafted the 1995 Southern Baptist Conference Resolution on Racial Reconciliation.
斯塔尔·帕克做了自我介绍。“我曾是一名依靠救济的母亲，”她说。那是过去。现在，她帮助管理着一个社会政策研究中心，这是她用自己成功的广告公司资金创立的。这是大卫·古希，一位伦理学教授，他起草了1995年美南浸信会关于种族和解的决议。
Here's a couple just back from Russia, where they've spent the last four years building churches. Gradually, the list fills out with real people who lead ordinary, fascinating lives. I listen to their stories and sense the change coming in the way Christians define our role in culture.
这是刚从俄罗斯回来的一对夫妇，他们在那里花了四年时间建造教堂。渐渐地，榜单填满了那些过着平凡而迷人生活的人。我听着他们的故事，感到了基督徒在定义我们文化角色的方式上即将发生的改变。
Here with her father is singer Rebecca St. James, 19 years old, described as part Mother Teresa, part Billy Graham. "Can you picture this?" she asks at her concerts. Then she tells a story reminiscent of the one in the book of Daniel, where Shadrach, Meshach, and Abednego face the furnace unless they bow before idols. "Our generation has its faces in the dirt, bowing down to the idols of materialism and selfishness. But you and I are like this." She clenches her eyes, throws her head back, and reaches heavenward with outstretched arms and open palms. "We will not bow."
和父亲一起来的是歌手丽贝卡·圣詹姆斯，19岁，被描述为“一部分是特蕾莎修女，一部分是比利·格雷厄姆”。“你能想象这个吗？”她在演唱会上问。然后她讲了一个让人想起《但以理书》的故事，讲到沙得拉、米煞和亚伯尼歌如果不在偶像面前下拜，就要面对火炉。“我们这一代人的脸贴在尘土里，向物质主义和自私的偶像下拜。但你和我不是这样的。”她闭上眼睛，头向后仰，张开双臂，手心向上，伸向天空。“我们不会下拜。”
That night after dinner, I look forward to hearing the keynote speaker, best known for a book written early in his career which is claimed to have influenced my generation of Christians, measured, naturally, in numbers of books sold. A mixed-race Florida gospel choir warms up the audience. We sing a few familiar choruses with them. All the women wear their hair big and high, as if they'd all plugged into the same electric socket.
那天晚饭后，我很期待听到主题演讲嘉宾的发言，他以早期职业生涯中所写的一本书而闻名，据说那本书影响了我们这一代基督徒，当然是以销量衡量的。一个多种族的佛罗里达福音合唱团热场。我们和他们唱了几首熟悉的副歌。所有的女性头发都高高隆起，好像都插在了同一个电源插座上。
The speaker presents his version of The Sky Is Falling. "We're facing the most rapid cultural change in history," he says. "Faster change than the change of the Enlightenment, the age of Darwin, the Renaissance, the Industrial Revolution, faster than the Space Age, the Television Age. Oh no, how will I keep up?" I hear him wondering. "How will my importance be determined?"
演讲者展示了他版本的“天塌了”。“我们正面临历史上最迅速的文化变革，”他说。“比启蒙运动、达尔文时代、文艺复兴、工业革命的变革还要快，比太空时代、电视时代还要快。噢，不，我该怎么跟上？”我听见他在纳闷。“我的重要性将如何被定义？”
This is the man with the short, well-meaning slogan, "Just Wait," a motto that's done as much for sexual abstinence, I'm guessing, among teens, as "Just Say No" has done for drug prevention. I mean this in conscious disrespect to a man who rails against the world in such hyperbolic terms, I feel embarrassed for him. He's wound up, soft in the middle. Where's his faith?
这就是那个带着简短、善意口号“再等等”的人，我猜，这个格言对于青少年的性禁欲所起的作用，就像“直接说不”对预防药物滥用所起的作用一样。我是说，这并非出于对一个用如此夸张术语抨击世界的人的不敬，我只是为他感到尴尬。他太紧张了，内容却空洞。他的信仰在哪里？
"We'd better wake up, or we'll be obsolete in three to five years," he's shouting and waving his arms now. "This is an anti-Judeo-Christian culture. Solve this riddle," he challenges his audience. "Why does a crucifix degraded in urine receive a major grant from the NEA, but a rainbow triangle in urine will not be funded nor allowed to be shown?" I've had enough, this riddle reminds me. I stand up and go to the ladies' room.
“我们最好清醒一点，否则三到五年内我们就会过时，”他正在大喊，挥舞着手臂。“这是一种反犹太-基督教文化。解开这个谜题，”他挑战观众。“为什么一个在尿液中降级的十字架能获得国家艺术基金会的大笔拨款，而一个在尿液中的彩虹三角形却不会获得资助，也不允许展示？”我已经受够了，这个谜题提醒我了。我站起来去了洗手间。
At breakfast the next morning, I'm grumpy and ready to fly home. And then, over scrambled eggs and coffee, I find the reason I came. Baroness Caroline Cox, from the British House of Lords, is speaking, a woman whose relief work I've watched with great admiration for the last two years, as I've edited a book on 20th-century martyrs. "There are some?" I'm often asked.
第二天早上早餐时，我脾气暴躁，准备飞回家。然后，在炒蛋和咖啡面前，我找到了我来的原因。英国上议院的卡罗琳·考克斯男爵夫人正在发言，过去两年里，我编辑一本关于20世纪殉道者的书时，一直带着崇敬的心情关注着她的救援工作。“真的有人吗？”人们常问我。
She tells us stories of Burma, and the Sudan, Pakistan, places where international relief agencies have been forbidden to go by the sovereign governments. And yet, with a small team of workers, she goes. "I am grateful for this opportunity to honor those Christians whom it has been our privilege to be with in persecution, brothers and sisters in Christ who, while we sit here in peace and comfort, are suffering from attempted genocide, jihad, ethnic cleansing, slavery, and threats of death for allegation of so-called blasphemy in fundamentalist Islamic regimes like Pakistan. But however much they suffer, they always inspire us with their courage, generosity, graciousness, faith, and dignity in their witness for our Lord."
她给我们讲述了缅甸、苏丹、巴基斯坦的故事，那些国际救援机构被主权政府禁止进入的地方。然而，带着一小队工作人员，她去了。“我非常感谢这个机会，向那些我们有幸在受迫害中与之相伴的基督徒致敬，那些在基督里的兄弟姐妹们，当我们在和平与舒适中坐着时，他们正遭受种族灭绝、圣战、种族清洗、奴役，并因在巴基斯坦等原教旨主义伊斯兰政权中被指控所谓的亵渎而面临死亡威胁。但无论他们遭受多大的痛苦，他们总是以勇气、慷慨、和蔼、信仰和尊严激励着我们，为我们的主作见证。”
Baroness Cox illegally flies in a load of cocaine, morphine, Omnopon, and Fentanyl for the amputees in Nagorno-Karabakh, where the Armenian people are blockaded and regularly bombed by their Azerbaijani tormentors. "God sometimes asks us to do strange things," she laughs, flipping to the next slide from a place in the world I've never heard of. "When I step off the plane, I am often greeted by starving, naked, wounded people in need of every human solace. I kneel with them," she says.
考克斯男爵夫人非法运送了一批可卡因、吗啡、奥诺邦和芬太尼，给纳戈尔诺-卡拉巴赫的截肢者，那里的人民被阿塞拜疆的迫害者封锁并定期轰炸。“上帝有时会要求我们做一些奇怪的事，”她笑着说，翻到下一张照片，来自世界上我从未听说过的地方。“当我下飞机时，我经常受到饥饿、赤身裸体、受伤的人们的迎接，他们需要一切人类的慰藉。我和他们跪在一起，”她说。
"On my last trip to Sudan, I saw a woman starving and gave her a sip of water from my thermos, as we stepped from the helicopter. A palliative. The next day, as I walked through the village, I found her dead."
“在上次去苏丹的旅行中，我看到一个挨饿的女人，我们从直升机上下来时，我给了她一口保温瓶里的水。一种姑息治疗。第二天，当我走过村庄时，发现她死了。”
And then this story of a farmer from northern Karabakh. "At the beginning of ethnic cleansing, Azerbaijan undertook a series of deportations of entire villages. They were brutal operations in which innocent villagers were rounded up. Many were maltreated, some murdered. Homes were ransacked. Then the people were forcibly driven off their land, unable to take anything with them.
然后是这个关于卡拉巴赫北部一个农夫的故事。“种族清洗开始时，阿塞拜疆进行了一系列整个村庄的驱逐。这是一次残酷的行动，无辜的村民被围捕。许多人遭到虐待，有些人被杀害。房屋被洗劫。然后人们被强行赶出土地，什么也带不走。”
"After one of these terrible events, at Getashen, a farmer managed to escape into the mountains. Devastated by what he had just witnessed, he saw an apricot tree in blossom and went to it for comfort, as it was so beautiful. Then, to his horror, he saw hanging from a branch, the body of a five-year-old Armenian girl, cut in two. He wept and vowed revenge."
“在格塔申发生的一次可怕事件之后，一个农夫设法逃进了山里。被他刚才目睹的一切摧毁了，他看到一棵杏树正在开花，便去寻求安慰，因为它太美了。然后，令他惊恐的是，他看到树枝上挂着一个五岁亚美尼亚女孩的身体，被砍成了两半。他哭着发誓要报仇。”
She apologizes to the room for the graphic scene she presents this morning. "It is how it is," she continues. "When we met him two years later, he wept again, telling us that he felt very bad, as he had broken his vow. For when the Armenians captured an Azeri village, he could not bring himself to harm a child. An American colleague stood up, removed his baseball cap, and said, 'Thank you. For the first time in my life, I understand what it means when it says in the Bible, "Vengeance is mine," saith the Lord. And thank you for the dignity you have shown.' To which this farmer replied, in words I will never forget, 'Dignity is a crown of thorns.'"
她为今早展示的血腥场面向大家致歉。“事实就是这样，”她继续说。“两年后我们见到他时，他又哭了，告诉我们他感到非常难过，因为他违背了誓言。因为当亚美尼亚人占领一个阿塞拜疆村庄时，他没能忍心去伤害一个孩子。一位美国同事站起来，摘下棒球帽说：‘谢谢。我这辈子第一次理解了圣经中说“申冤在我”是什么意思。谢谢你展现出的尊严。’那个农夫回答了，他说了一句我永远不会忘记的话：‘尊严是荆棘王冠。’”
It's here in this stale, no-frills room among the older Christians and the young that I meet those too busy doing the work of justice and kindness to point the finger at other people for not being Christian enough. "We are a splendidly ecumenical mix of Pentecostal, Russian orthodox, and myself," the Baroness laughs musically, "which I shall call Anglican unorthodox." Suddenly, the room is large enough for us all. Everyone is needed on the list. Our differences in age and gender and culture fall away, as we are given to see a destitution so vast, it will take us all to help begin to relieve it.
就在这个老旧、朴实无华的房间里，在年长的基督徒和年轻的基督徒中间，我遇到了那些忙于从事正义与仁慈工作的人，他们没空指责别人因为不够虔诚。“我们是一个五旬节派、俄罗斯东正教徒和我组成的华丽而多元的组合，”男爵夫人音乐般地笑着说，“我可以称之为‘圣公会非正统’。”突然，房间变大了，足以容纳我们所有人。每个人在名单上都是必须的。我们年龄、性别和文化的差异消散了，因为我们看到了一种如此巨大的贫困，以至于需要我们所有人共同努力才能开始减轻它。
The Baroness closes her talk with some lines written by Father John Harriet which she uses as a benediction. "Let us mourn 'til others are comforted, weep 'til others laugh. Let us be sleepless 'til all can sleep untroubled. Let us be frugal 'til all are filled. Let us give 'til all have received. Let us make no claim 'til all have had their due. Let us be slaves 'til all are free. Let us lay down our lives 'til all have life abundantly."
男爵夫人用约翰·哈里特神父写的一段 benediction（祝福词）结束了她的谈话。“让我们哀悼，直到别人得到安慰；哭泣，直到别人欢笑。让我们彻夜难眠，直到所有人都能无忧地入睡。让我们节俭，直到所有人都能吃饱。让我们奉献，直到所有人都有所获。让我们不提要求，直到所有人都得到了应得的。让我们成为奴隶，直到所有人都获得自由。让我们献出生命，直到所有人都能拥有丰盛的生命。”
Susan Bergman is the editor of Martyrs, an anthology of essays on 20th-century martyrs, and author of the forthcoming novel The Buried Life.
苏珊·伯格曼是《殉道者》的编辑，这是一本关于20世纪殉道者的文章选集，也是即将出版的小说《埋葬的生活》的作者。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Elise Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Alex Blumberg and Rachel Howard.
好吧，今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我本人制作，埃莉斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克协助。高级编辑保罗·塔夫。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自亚历克斯·布隆伯格和瑞秋·霍华德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[感谢名单]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买此节目或我们任何节目的盒式录音带，请拨打芝加哥WBEZ电台电话：312-832-3380，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址：[email protected]。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who can only explain our presence on his radio station this way.
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他只能这样解释我们在他电台的存在。
It was ludicrous and paranoid to think about foul play, but it did cross my mind.
认为有人想加害我是荒谬和多疑的，但这确实在我脑海中闪过。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。